this is now a day 20 of the war in
ukraine and to go through developments
with me i'm joined by defence and
security analyst michael clark now we
haven't seen much movement have we from
russian forces over the last week but
it's clear something's happening in kiev
we've seen heavy shelling there yes uh
kiev has suffered some rocket attacks
and that's the first of what might turn
out to be rather more
the russians haven't got round to the
south of kiev as quickly as we thought
they're still making hard work of it but
one of the reasons that they're fighting
so hard for these towns and cities in
the northwest uh like urpin and uh
brook
and bravery is that those towns are just
about a ring about 15 or 20 miles away
which is just about the range of russian
artillery and once they go past those
towns they can bring their big howitzers
in not the rockets but the howitzers and
they can threaten to just reduce kiev
with good old-fashioned artillery shells
that's what
the battle is really all about up in the
northwest yeah and when you look at the
other advance of the russian forces we
can see the north and south now but
they're not quite joined up are they so
obviously that is clear that's the
strategy now of course they want to join
up these areas because they want their
armies to unite but they've got to go
further west than that because what they
want to try to do is actually encircle
the ukrainian armies and to do that
they've actually got to get outside of
them so they've still got a bigger job
to do to literally
move up from south to north somewhere
west of where they now are that'll be
quite a big job and ultimately they've
got to move up the valley of denebra and
they've got to do something about niprio
that'll be a real problem for them and
let's now move further south um what's
happening there
uh mikalayev uh mikolav is the gateway
to odessa uh mikolav is a big important
port
um very big area it's being defended
ferociously
and as the russians have moved out of
crimea which is their secure base quite
short lines of of uh communication
they're attacking mcleod but mikolaiv
is is a place that's on the southern bug
estuary so it's a place that's a delta
there's a great deal of water there and
to any attacking force that's a problem
so let's just take a little look a bit
closer there we've got some satellite
images that will show us now um that
bridge in more detail yeah um so talk us
through the geography obviously as you
mentioned a lot of water here yeah there
it is the city occupies these peninsulas
it's based to the effectively to the
east of the great river this is the
southern bug river in english and there
is the
vavaviskya bridge about a mile long um
any attacking commander will look at
this map and say there's an awful lot of
water to get over here and the chances
of taking that bridge intact if they get
into the city are extremely remote i'd
be amazed if that bridge was not
extremely well mined by the ukrainians
they'll blow it before they withdraw if
they go over it so this is a real
problem and when they get over mcclain
when they get over the the sub the south
berg estuary it's still 80 miles to
odessa so they've still got quite a lot
to do
thank you so much